Sometimes we feel some jerks while sleeping. Do
we know what it is called? It is called
Hypnic Jag
or if we say it in simple language then it
is Sleep Start. What happens in this?
Our brain is here.  There are two types of
centers present in the brain. The first is the reticular
activation system, which controls our
daily activities which are conscious. The second
is our pre-
optic nucleus, which is our pre-optic
nucleus. What does it do at the time of sleep?
Which causes sleep paralysis
so that we do not wake up
when we sleep. Sometimes our RAS is
not able to function properly and this is
your preoptic nucleus. What it
does is it starts sending signals.  Due to
which our brain gets confused
and this causes your hypnic-
jags condition.